Jeff Sharkey:
Well, hey, everybody,
thanks for coming
this afternoon.
My name is Jeff Sharkey,
and I've been working on Android
for about a year and a half
outside of the Google team.
And then recently,
about six months ago,
I joined Google,
and I've been working on some
cool stuff in the meantime.
And today we're gonna talk
about battery life.
So you guys got a whole bunch
of really cool devices
this morning.
How many of you still have
charge left on your device?
You still have
some battery life.
Okay, there's still
some hands in the crowd.
You might notice,
as you go through the day,
you'll slowly watch
that battery life go down
further and further,
and then the device will die.
And that's something that
today we're gonna talk about--
you as developers, as you're
writing these applications,
writing third-party
applications,
ways that you can make
that battery last longer...
for your users
that are out on the field,
not just for yourselves.
So just wanted to mention
up front
that as I go through
the talk today,
if you guys have any questions,
if they come to you
during the presentation--
I'm using Google Moderator,
so you should have
received links.
There's links up on
the screen right there.
The haveasec--I don't know
if that goes to the right one.
But this link,
code.google.com,
that'll link you guys
to the Moderator,
and then at the end
of the talk.
There's a couple questions
up there already,
it looks like, on it.
So I'll be switching
back and forth
between the mikes
and the Moderator
at the end of the session.
So just a heads-up--
if you have questions, go ask,
and also vote,
'cause that'll bubble up
the important questions
to the top.
All right, so battery life.
Why does it matter?
Why does it matter
to the users that are out there?
When we think of Android
devices, we typically--
they're mostly phones right now.
And these phones, they might
be on someone's nightstand,
and then they take them out
for the rest of an entire day.
They leave in the morning.
They unplug the device.
And that device
may not see power,
it may not see a charge,
until that person gets home
late that night.
So during the course of the day,
the battery needs to power
the device.
And the risk is
that if the battery
runs out during the day,
the user can't use
the device anymore.
When the battery's gone,
it truly is gone.
It's a sad state of affairs.
So the apps needs to work
together to be good citizens
of the battery
that's on the device,
because you're
all running together.
Your app is running alongside
Gmail and Maps
and a lot of these other apps
on the device.
So you need to work together
with those apps
to be good citizens.
Today I'll be throwing around
a bunch of different numbers,
and I'll be using
two units of measurement.
They're actually SI units.
The first type of measurement
I'll be talking about
is current,
or typically
we think of this in amps,
or milliamps is the unit
I'll be using today.
So if you think--
current is a way of saying
how fast we're consuming
the battery on the device
or the rate of consumption.
So when you're doing
a lot on the device,
let's say you're watching
a YouTube video,
you'll be pulling a lot
of milliamps on the device.
The second number
I'll be mentioning
is milliamp hours,
and that's a capacity.
That's how much storage,
how much battery life
we actually store
in the battery on the device
when it is fully charged.
So just some numbers
for comparison.
If we think of the HTC Dream
or the G1 device
that recently came out
last Octoberish,
it had a battery
of 1,150 milliamp hours.
That was the capacity
that it could hold.
The device that you guys
received today,
the HTC Magic,
has a slightly larger battery,
about 1,350.
And another device that was
also recently announced
in a press release,
a Samsung device
that runs Android,
and its battery
is about 1,500 milliamp hours.
So something to realize between
all three of these devices
is that they roughly have
the same battery--
the same battery capacity.
They're all in the same class.
It's roughly the same.
And this is partially
an industrial design problem.
When you're building a phone,
you want to build something
that fits in someone's pocket.
You don't want to build a device
that they have to carry around
a 12-volt battery with them.
[laughs]
You want to have a device
that fits nicely
in their pocket.
So you only have so much
room for a battery.
And the way the technology
is progressing right now,
we're looking forward to having
better battery life
in the future,
or better battery capacities.
But for the moment,
this is kind of
what we have to deal with.
Just to compare
these capacities,
something like a typical
laptop that you might see,
like a Asus EEE PC,
its battery is about
three or four times the size
of what we're dealing with
on these mobile devices.
It's about 5,800
milliamp hours.
And that's about the same as
if you know a MacBook Pro,
the battery in that's about
5,600 milliamp hours.
So those are the types of
numbers that we're dealing with.
So then we can ask the question,
we have the capacity,
we have
the 1,150 milliamp hours--
where does it all go
through the course of a day
as the user's doing
different tasks?
So this is just an overview.
If we start over
on the left-hand side,
if you have a device,
it's booted,
but the screen's turned off.
It's sitting on the table
completely idle.
And it's in airplane mode.
This means we've turned off
all the radios in the device.
It takes about 2 milliamp hours
or 2 milliamps of current
that it's pulling
just to sit there waiting
for the user to wake it up--
waiting for a user to wake it up
and interact with it.
If we add in one of
the radio connections--
let's say if we have an EDGE
or a 3G connection
just sitting idle--it takes
a slightly little bit more.
It's about 5 milliamps
that the device is pulling
just sitting there idle.
On WiFi,
it costs a little bit more,
about 12 milliamps
of current that it's pulling.
As soon as the user begins
interacting with the device,
this is where
we see the jump.
Just turning on the LCD
on the device
to display something
to the user
ends up taking
90 milliamps of battery.
So anytime the screen is on,
that's the amount of current
that the screen is pulling.
And as soon as we start
adding in things like CPU...
if you're doing 50%
or 100% CPU--
so 100% CPU on top of
the screen already being on,
so this is the blue
specific item--
on top of the screen being
turned on,
100% CPU ends up being
110 milliamps
to run the CPU
at full speed.
Something if you're looking
at writing a game,
running the game sensor,
so the accelerometer
on the device,
this takes something like
80 milliamps
of current
that you're pulling.
If you're trying to get
a GPS fix using the GPS radio,
that ends up taking another
80 or 85 milliamps
that that radio is pulling.
And then finally we get
to the data on the device,
when you have a data radio
turned on
and you're doing data transfer.
So these numbers
are full-bore.
We're transferring as much data
as we possibly can.
So this is--we're stressing
the radio out,
we're doing
lots of data transfer.
So something like this.
The 3G radio is actually
pretty cheap in the device.
It ends up costing
about 150 milliamps
just to run the 3G radio
full-bore
so that you're transferring
a lot of data.
On an EDGE connection,
it costs about 250 milliamps
to run that radio at full-speed.
And then finally, WiFi,
which costs the most.
It's about 275 milliamps
to run that at full-speed.
So now that we know
where it actually goes,
let's compare those numbers.
Let's take a moment
and step back
and think,
do these numbers make sense?
Do these match up with
the real life battery statistics
we're seeing in the field?
So let's take
a couple of examples.
Let's say you're watching
a YouTube video.
So this is something--
we're watching it on 3G.
So we have the 3G radio
spun up.
We're doing a good amount
of data transfer.
We're transferring video.
The CPU's doing a lot of work.
It's decoding the video
and then putting it
on the screen for the user.
And then they have
the LCD on.
So in total,
watching a YouTube video,
it's pulling about
340 milliamps of current.
That's how much current
it's using to show the video.
And so we have those
two units of measurement,
or those two units,
and we can divide it
by the capacity in the device,
and we can figure out how long
the device should last,
the expected life
of the device.
So something playing
a YouTube video,
at 1,150 milliamp hours,
the capacity in the battery
should last us about
3 1/2 hours of actual use,
of the person, if they watched
YouTube video continuously.
Something a little more
typical--browsing the 3G web.
So it's a little bit cheaper.
We're not doing as much
data transfer.
It's about 225 milliamps
or about
five hours of battery life.
So that's if the user's
sitting there
interacting with the device
solid for three or four hours.
A more typical use case
is that they pull it
out of their pocket
maybe once or twice an hour.
They're not interacting
with it very much.
Most of the time
it's in their pocket.
So a typical use case,
we can think of
the device being turned on
about ten minutes
out of every hour.
So we have the device turned on
and doing activities
for about ten minutes,
and the other 50 minutes
of that hour,
the device
is in the person's pocket.
It's asleep.
It's using
very little current.
So if we average that out,
it's about 42 milliamps
on average, over an hour.
So if we do the computation,
that battery life ends up--
the battery life
in that case
ends up being about
32 hours.
And that's fairly typical.
That's usually what we're seeing
from people out in the field
that are using G1 devices.
They usually see a battery life
that lasts them about a day.
So then let's take a look at
the other end of the spectrum.
Let's say we have a device
that's just sitting there
completely idle.
The user isn't interacting
with it at all.
So the number that we measured
earlier was 5 milliamps.
That's the amount of current
that it was pulling.
If we do the math--
the 1,150 milliamp hours,
the capacity of the battery,
should last us
about 9 1/2 days
and even further
if we have the device
in an airplane mode.
So all the radios
are turned off,
we're only pulling
that 2 milliamps,
it should last about
24 days.
Then we can ask the question,
where did
all that battery life go?
What's happening
in between?
What costs the most?
What are we doing
in the background
that's using
all of that battery,
all of that capacity
that the phone could use
to last longer?
So we can ask the question,
what costs the most?
And the first thing
at the top of the list
is waking up in the background,
and this is when the phone
would otherwise be asleep
in your pocket.
You can have background tasks
that wake up
to go check the person's email,
say every 15 or 20 minutes
or every half hour.
Or maybe an incoming email
comes in
and needs to do
some network activity.
Things that the device
wakes up to do in the background
when it would
otherwise be asleep
end up costing a lot
towards battery life.
So let's take
a typical example.
Let's say you're writing
an app that checks RSS feeds
for new incoming posts.
And let's check
every ten minutes.
So this is just an example app
just for the sake of example.
And when it wakes up
in the background,
it probably takes
about eight seconds
to perform a full update.
When you think of it,
we're pulling up
the radio stack,
we're going and we're doing
a DNS request,
doing a network connection,
pulling down the page,
doing parsing on the device.
And then it takes a few seconds
for the device
to settle back down
and fall into
a sleep mode again.
So about eight seconds.
And the battery usage
during that period
is about 300--
let's say 350 milliamps.
We don't have the screen on,
but we're using a lot of data
and a lot of CPU.
So now let's take a look
at what this would cost
during a given hour.
So the idle cost,
if the device was completely
idle for that hour,
it would cost us about
5 milliamp hours.
That's the cost of the device
just sitting there
completely idle.
But as soon as we add in
this application
that's waking up
in the background,
doing these seemingly innocent--
just going out and checking,
checking in our assess feed,
we do the math--
six times every ten minutes,
six times an hour times the
eight seconds for each update,
times the 350 milliamps.
The amount of current
that we're using there
is about 4.6 milliamp hours.
That's the amount that we're
taking for this app to run.
So just this small,
innocent app
is actually cutting
the user's battery life in half.
And that's really something
to realize.
Apps like these are waking up,
and they can start using
a lot of the user's battery
without them even knowing.
They think the device is turned
off and in their pocket.
And another thing to realize
is that these apps waking up,
it's not just your update
that might happen.
On the system,
we have a notion of services
that can only wake up,
that can set alarms
for themselves,
that only wake up when
the device is already awake.
So if the device--if you
force the device awake,
other services may piggyback
on top of your waking up
of the device.
So it actually--
it compounds itself.
Other apps jump on,
and you can cascade a trigger--
or you can trigger a cascade
of several of these updates
all happening
at the same time.
So it might not just be
your eight seconds.
If you wake up
for your eight seconds,
you might end up forcing
the phone awake
for 15 or 20 seconds
as other apps try to pile on
and do their updates as well.
[coughs]
So what else
costs the most?
Another thing that costs a lot
is bulk data transfer.
So we have phones
with data connections.
You can think of them
transferring bulk data.
We have people that are
watching videos on YouTube.
We have people
that are generating content.
They're taking pictures
and videos,
and they want to upload those.
So we have heavy data traffic
in both directions.
And it ends up
that bulk data transfer
can actually cost a lot
towards the life
of a person's battery.
So if we look at three different
types of data connections
that are available
on the phone today,
we have an EDGE connection,
a 3G, and a WiFi connection.
And they all cost roughly
about the same,
anywhere from 210
to 330 milliamps.
Those numbers
are slightly different
'cause we're including CPU
in those numbers
from the numbers
that I mentioned earlier.
That's why
they're slightly different.
So they all cost roughly
in the same ballpark
to run those data connections.
The key differentiator
is that they can transfer
at different rates.
A 3G connection
is a lot more efficient.
It can transfer data a lot
faster than an EDGE connection.
Or even if you're familiar,
there's a notion of
a GPRS connection
which is even slower
than EDGE--
which is
even slower than EDGE,
whereas WiFi can transfer
stuff a lot faster.
So let's take an example
of a 6 megabyte song.
You're writing a music store
application
for a person
to go buy music,
and you need to transfer
6 megabytes down to the phone.
This is just bulk data transfer.
We can do the math,
and we can figure out
how long it would take
in each of those cases.
To do that transfer on EDGE,
it takes about nine minutes.
But to do it on WiFi,
which is a lot faster,
it takes under a minute,
about 46, 48 seconds.
But then, consider
that we have to multiply that
by how much the battery
is being used over that time.
So something like an EDGE
transfer, the nine minutes,
ends up costing us
45 milliamp hours.
That's how much battery we're
using to do that data transfer.
That same data transfer,
that same 6 megabytes
would cost us
an order of magnitude less
if we did it over WiFi,
if we waited around
to get a faster connection.
It costs only less than
5 milliamp hours.
So it's less than 10%
of the original cost.
Other things
that end up costing a lot
are moving between
cells and networks.
So as the phone--
you can think of a phone,
as a person commutes with it
different locations,
the phone radio ramps up
to associate with new cells.
So as I drove here
this morning on a bus,
my phone transferred between
multiple cell towers
as I went along the road,
if you're riding Caltrain
or something like that.
So this is something
we can't avoid,
the radio chipset needs to
wake up and be always associated
so that the user can receive
incoming text
and incoming phone calls.
But on Android,
we also wake up the system
to possibly deal--
Maybe your app,
maybe an app on the system
is interested
when the connectivity changes.
For example,
if you have a photo
that the user
wanted to upload,
you might want to check to see
if the network connection
goes up and down.
So if the network connection
comes back up,
you may want to finish
uploading your video.
So we actually--
the Android operating system
allows us to wake up
applications in the background
using the notion
of broadcast intents.
I'll get into that
a little bit later,
but those actually
cost a lot towards battery,
especially when we're waking up
those applications
and they aren't
going to do anything.
If we wake it up to tell it
network connectivity changed
and it decides,
"I don't need to do anything,"
it can end up costing a lot.
Two other things in the end
that end up costing a lot
are textual data.
So if we're receiving
that RSS feed down from XML,
parsing that on the device
can actually be
really expensive.
We're walking through
the text data,
we're trying to parse it.
You can think of all
the different data formats
that you might have out there,
XML or JSON or even YAML,
Yet Another Markup Language,
which is--its structure
is based on spaces,
so there's a lot of textual data
that it has to parse through.
So parsing through text data
that comes from the web
can be really expensive,
and I'll touch on that
a little bit later
the differences between them.
And finally, another thing
that ends up costing a lot
on the device
is regular expressions,
especially on Android.
So the current virtual
machine that we're using,
the Dalvik VM, doesn't have
just-in-time compiling,
which is a luxury
that a lot of people are used to
from the desktop world.
So in a desktop
virtual machine,
if we run into
a regular expression,
the desktop machine can actually
compile a regular expression
into really fast, tight code
that runs very efficiently.
But on a platform like Android,
the current virtual machine
that doesn't support
just-in-time compiling,
this can actually be
pretty expensive.
It can't optimize that
just yet.
So those are some things
to be aware of.
So then we can ask
the question--
we know what the battery
capacity that we're looking at.
We know what things cost.
And now we know
what things actually
cost a lot on the device.
So how can we do better
as we're developers,
as we're out there
writing apps?
Today I'll be splitting this up
into three separate sections.
We're gonna talk first about
foreground applications.
First we'll talk about
networking,
then foreground apps,
and finally background apps.
So first, networking.
Check the network connection.
So this comes back
to you're about to do
a set of bulk data transfers.
You have that 6 megabyte song
that the user
wants to have downloaded.
Something that you can do
as a developer
is you can check
the current network connection
that the user is on,
that the device is on.
So for example,
if you know you need
to download a lot of data,
maybe you'll hold off
on that transfer
until the user comes into
an area with 3G coverage
or they connect
to a WiFi network.
So this is a quick
code snippet example
that...Android makes it
really easy
to check to see what kind
of network you're on.
So I skipped past it.
It was on the first slide here.
There's a notion
of a connectivity
and a telephony manager
that you can get references to
if you have a context in Java.
So with
the connectivity manager,
we can get an instance
of the current network info,
and that's what
this info object is.
And we can probe it.
We can ask it what type
of network we're on,
that the user is currently on,
what subtype of network.
And then we can do
some pretty quick logic
to check to see if we should
actually perform a transfer.
So in this case,
the first if block
is checking to see
if we're on a network connection
of type WiFi,
and if that's the type
that's currently enabled
and we're connected
to that network, return true.
Let's actually perform
the data transfer,
'cause WiFi's fast.
It'll be cheap.
Otherwise, if we're on
a mobile network...
let's check to see
if we're on a 3G network.
Another name for this
is UMTS.
There's several different
3G technologies,
but this is the one
that we have the constants for
in the platform right now.
And finally, one other thing
that you can do as developers
is you might be smart--
you might check to see
if the user's roaming.
Roaming data can end up
costing users a lot,
so if this is just something
in the background
and you're offering to download
music for the user,
this can end up costing a lot,
especially not only time
and battery-wise,
but monetarily,
when they get their bill
at the end of the month.
So this is just one of those
flags that we can check to see
is the network roaming,
some stuff that we can check
to help our users in the end.
So if that returns true,
we can go ahead
if we're actually connected
to a 3G network
and we're not roaming.
Otherwise,
we can return false.
Some other choices here too.
Instead of
just returning false,
you might choose to involve
the user in the process.
So if the user takes a video
and they wanna upload it online,
if you know that you're
on an EDGE connection,
you might actually
do the math--
do some quick math
in the code to see:
would I be able to transfer
this without killing the device?
Is there enough
battery life left?
And you might involve
the user in the process
and just tell them,
transferring this file--
transferring this raw data
over EDGE--
is gonna cost you a lot.
You might actually lose
your device,
because it would suck
all the battery life
out of your device,
and I may not even finish.
And you might ask the user
if they really want
to go ahead with that.
So instead of just
blanketedly canceling,
you might involve them
with that process
and allow them
to override it,
'cause there's certain
instances where they may
really want photos
to be uploaded right away.
It also allows them
to be aware of--
so if they're on
an EDGE connection
and you inform them,
they might know of
a WiFi hotspot down the street
that they can go connect to.
So involving them
in that process can really--
you're helping them
save battery.
One other thing
that we can check.
So this is jumping back
a slide.
In the Settings app right now,
Settings and Synchronization,
there's a check box in there,
and the user can change
the preference
for using background data.
Right now, all of the Google
services that are on the device
look at that check box,
and that's how they figure out
what the user wants to do
as far as data happening
in the background on the device.
So if the user un-checks
that box,
the Google services
will actually turn off,
and they will only synchronize
if the user goes into the app
and forces it,
or if they come back
and turn on this check box.
So this is something
you as developers
can also run in a check.
If you have
a connectivity manager object,
you can check to see
the state of that flag.
And this is something
that's new in Cupcake.
And I'll be mentioning
a couple of features
that have come out
in the Cupcake
or the 1.5 SDK
that recently came out,
and I'll just indicate them
with a little icon over there
on the right.
So that's just something
to be aware of
as we go through the rest
of the presentation today.
So we talked about...
we talked about
bulk data transfer
involving the user
in that process.
One of the other things
that can cost us a lot
networking-wise
is doing textual data,
is transferring and parsing
that text data.
And as developers, we have
a lot of different choices.
A lot of us have
a favored data format
that we like pushing stuff
across the web.
If you come from a restful
approach of doing web services,
maybe you're used to XML.
Or maybe you wrap your data
in a JSON format.
Or maybe you're used to other
different formats
such as YAML,
Yet Another Markup Language,
or some of
these other formats.
Another popular protocol--
or another popular data format
for passing stuff
across the web
is using a binary format.
So if you're used to
something called ASN.1,
it's a public standard
for parsing,
for packaging and parceling
binary data across the web.
Or something we've developed
here, it's similar.
It's another binary form.
It's called protocol buffers.
It's something that we've
open sourced here at Google.
And so it's a slightly more
efficient way
of packing data
across the network.
So you have
all of these choices
for the different protocols
when communicating
with the device.
So we can ask the question,
which one is the cheapest?
What are the best choices?
So it boils down--
we need to back up a second,
and we need ask ourselves
the question,
what type of parser
are we actually going to use
on the device?
Most parsers fall into
one of two categories.
It's either a tree parser
or an event
or stream-based parser.
So a tree parser
is something,
if you're used to
in the desktop world
of working with a DOM
or the Document Object Model
in a browser,
it parses the entire document
into an in-memory tree
that then you can go
and interact with
and pull data out of.
But that tree can become
really expensive
on a mobile device.
You're building
the entire document
into an in-memory structure.
And maybe you're just going
and pulling some of the data
out of that tree,
and then you end up
having to dispose it.
It becomes garbage that the
system then has to collect.
It become somewhat wasteful.
So tree parsers can be
pretty wasteful in these cases,
because they're generating
a lot of garbage.
On the flip side,
an event
or a stream-based parser
allows you as a developer
to become directly involved
with the parsing process.
So as the parser
walks along a document,
it might-- it actually has
callbacks to your code
saying "I found the beginning
of a tag or the end of a tag,"
or maybe "I found
a section of text or a number
or an XML attribute."
And it can make these callbacks
for you to handle in your code.
It allows you to become
directly involved
with the parsing process.
The key takeaway there
is to realize
that event
or stream-based parsers
can be a lot more efficient
memory-wise than tree parsers.
So this slide is a comparison
on the device.
Let's say we have
a six-item RSS feed
that we want to pull down
and parse from the web.
And let's look at it
from a number
of different data formats.
Let's choose three.
We have XML or JSON
or protocol buffers,
which is a binary format.
So in this case,
we see on the left
those tree parsers in gray
end up being pretty expensive.
It takes a lot of time
to actually parse and handle
those documents.
But then we see
on the right-hand side
when we're using the event
or stream-based parsers,
it ends up being
a lot cheaper,
especially when we can see
the stair-step effect.
XML is a little bit less
efficient than JSON.
And then protocol buffers,
because it's a binary
data format,
ends up being
pretty efficient.
Ends up being
the most efficient
out of the ones
that we compared here.
So the key takeaway is
use those stream parsers
instead of the tree parsers.
So this is something
if you're using XML pull parser
on the device,
that's one of the good parsers
that you should be using.
Sad to say the JSON object
and the JSON array libraries
that ship with the platform...
they're tree parsers right now.
So it's something
we'd like to find
other libraries to integrate.
So it's something
to be aware of
if you're parsing JSON data
on the device--
the ones that ship with
the framework are tree parsers.
So they're slightly
less efficient.
There's other libraries
that you can use in their place.
For example, the numbers
that I did on the last slide,
I used Jackson,
with is another JSON library
which allows it to parse
as a stream.
So we have text formats,
then we also have
these binary formats,
like protocol buffers
or the ASN.1.
Another benefit to using
the binary formats like that
is that we can incorporate
both text and binary data
in the same request.
And one place this is
actually evident on the platform
is in the Market client.
If you're scrolling through
a list of apps in Market,
you might notice
that all of the sudden
five--four or five icons
of the apps
that you're browsing through
just appear
all of the sudden.
They don't slowly fill in.
You'll see five at once.
And the reason is
we're using protocol buffers
to actually bundle up
multiple requests
into a single request,
and then we return the images
in one bunch to the device.
And this is really helpful
on some mobile networks
that can be laggy,
where you have a lot of latency
between yourself and the server.
So instead of making
an individual request
for each of those assets,
for each of those icons,
we actually wrap that
into a single request,
requesting four or five,
and we get
a larger response back
that then we can parse.
So something like a binary
format like protocol buffers
allows us to pack
even multiple files
into a single request
coming back to the device.
And that can really help you
have fewer round trips
and serve faster
user experience
to people
that are using your apps.
One other way that we can
actually do a good job
on the device as far
as networking is using GZIP.
If you're familiar with
the desktop environment,
some web servers
support the notion
of compressing the data before
they send it to the browser,
and almost all modern browsers,
automatically, when they see
GZIP data coming from a website,
will decompress it
and show it to the user.
So many of you have actually
used this in browsers today,
possibly without realizing
that it's happening
under the hood.
So to back up a second,
GZIP is compressing the data.
The server compresses the data
before it sends it
across the network,
and the device handles it.
So in Android,
the GZIP libraries
that come with the platform
are really efficient.
And that's in part because
they go directly to native code
on the device.
So if you're parsing
a GZIP stream coming in,
if you're decompressing it,
it ends up being
incredibly efficient,
incredibly fast.
So here's a quick example.
If you're using something like
the Apache HTTP client library,
something a lot of us
have used in our code,
the first set of code
should be--
the first couple lines there
should be pretty familiar.
We're making
a get request website
and receiving something back.
But in this case,
if we know, for instance,
that the web server
we're talking to
is going to be sending back
compressed data,
we only need to add
one line of code,
one extra step
to decompress that data.
We take the input stream
that we're receiving
from the site,
and we just wrap it
in a GZIP input stream.
The system on the fly
will decompress the data
coming from the server
and so we can continue
handling it.
So we can pass
that input stream,
the decompressed one,
into one of our data format
parsers earlier
that takes an input stream
into it.
So GZIP on the platform
goes directly to native code,
and it's really cheap.
So we can ask the question,
how cheap is it?
Should I consider using this?
So just for the sake
of an example,
let's say we had
a large RSS feed,
say like a thousand items.
And this is what I did
for this test.
So if we're on a WiFi connection
which is really fast,
it doesn't make
too much of a difference.
We're looking here
at the three bars,
the raw data itself,
so the raw XML,
and then we compressed it
using two levels
of GZIP compression.
Those are
the two blue colors.
And that's just the two levels.
1 is light compression
and 9 is the heaviest
compression available.
So in WiFi, it doesn't make
too much of a difference.
But as soon as we start
going over to a 3G
or an EDGE connection,
we can begin to see
where the value of compressing
the data comes in.
So on a 3G network connection,
just by compressing the data
as it comes across the network,
we end up cutting the transfer
and parsing time,
that total time, in half.
And so it's not just
the parsing time.
Remember
that this is battery time,
because the radio is spun out
that entire time.
The CPU is spun up.
It's waiting for data.
It's parsing it.
So this is the user's
battery life.
We've essentially,
in terms of our application,
we've doubled the user's
battery life on 3G.
And it's even better on EDGE.
EDGE to do this transfer,
to transfer it across
and parse it,
ended up taking over
40 seconds.
But that same data
transferred across the network,
if we GZIP it,
if we compress it,
ends up taking
under ten seconds.
So again,
an order of magnitude,
it's ten times more expensive
to do the raw data.
Another thing
to take away from this slide,
you might wonder how expensive
are the GZIP libraries
on the device.
So we can see that
with the WiFi connection
on the far right,
we're seeing that adding GZIP
doesn't cost us anything.
It doesn't take us longer
to parse the data,
even when we have
a really fast connection.
And then one final thing
to mention about GZIP is
this is really helpful when
you're working with text data.
Text data can be really
well-compressed using GZIP.
If you're doing
binary transfers,
if you're doing images
or video,
those items,
because they're binary data,
don't compress as well.
So experiment with the data
that you're using
to see how well it compresses
to see if this would
actually be an advantage.
For most binary formats,
like the images and video,
it won't actually offer you
very much savings.
Okay, so we talked about
networking.
Another thing
that we can talk about
is foreground applications
that we're interacting with,
that the user interacts with
on the device.
So if you're writing an app,
there's a note of wakelocks
that you can acquire
to keep the device awake.
Let's say, for example, you're
writing a video application
that you want the user
to sit and watch videos in,
something like YouTube.
You can acquire a wakelock,
which forces the device
to stay awake
at least a certain level.
There's multiple levels
of wakelocks in Android.
You could request--
one of the lowest levels
is just one that forces
the CPU to stay on.
So you acquire this lock
that the system knows
someone out there
needs the CPU to be turned on.
And then
when you're finished,
let's say you're parsing
the document,
you can release
that wakelock.
And if the system--if the user
isn't doing anything,
releasing that wakelock
would allow the system
to fall back asleep.
Like I was saying,
there's multiple levels
of these wakelocks.
That's just one
that would keep the CPU on.
We can have other ones that,
for example,
keep the LCD on,
which is very useful for
something playing back video.
We want the screen to stay on
so the user
doesn't have to actively
interact with the screen.
Wakelocks can be really useful
because they allow you,
as developers, power
in keeping the device awake.
But on the flip side, they can
actually be really expensive,
especially
if you forget to release them,
because even though
we're working in the Java...
in a Java world,
wakelocks actually...
the system acquires them,
and it doesn't
garbage collect them.
If you take out a wakelock
and you forget to release it,
the system still thinks
that you're out there,
having acquired it,
and it will keep
the system awake.
So if your code crashes
or if you forget to release
the wakelock,
you might be responsible
for keeping the device awake
for a long period of time
and possibly draining
the user's battery.
If you acquire wakelock
and don't release it,
the system will stay awake
that entire time
and possibly
not allow it to fall asleep.
So if you're worried
about correctness--
'cause I was mentioning
there's these wakelocks;
you have to acquire
and release them--
if you're worried about
the correctness,
of proving that your code
is correct,
that you'll actually
release them at the right time,
there's one of two approaches
you can use.
If you're writing UI
from a user perspective,
you can add one single tag
into your UI,
into any of the layouts,
the Android layouts in XML--
and that's
android:keepScreenOn="true".
Just using that,
if you add that tag
you'll keep the screen on,
and you don't
have to worry about
going and acquiring
wakelocks.
You don't
have to go touch them.
The window manager
in the device
will actually acquire a wakelock
on your behalf
when your application shows,
and then whether you crash
or the user switches
to a different application,
as soon as your activity
goes away,
the system will,
on your behalf,
release that wakelock.
So that can be one way
of guaranteeing the correctness
if you just need
to keep the screen on.
Another way is if you're
acquiring these wakelocks
behind the scene, say,
to keep the CPU awake
while you're performing
some parsing,
you can actually set a limit.
You can say I'd like
to acquire this wakelock
for, at most, 30 seconds,
or for, at most, a minute.
So if you know how long
the worst-case parsing
is going to take,
you can actually use that
when you acquire the wakelock.
So if the system
doesn't hear back from you
by the time
that time-out elapses,
the system will automatically
release the wakelock.
So if you know you're just
parsing an RSS feed image
and it shouldn't take any longer
than 30 seconds,
you can actually
just set that as the time out,
and the system will release it
on your behalf.
So just in case there are
any lagging issues in the code,
any correctness issues,
the system will release it
on your behalf
when the time out passes.
Another way we can help save
battery from a UI perspective
is recycling Java objects,
especially complex ones.
So, yes, on Android,
we have a garbage collector.
So we can create objects,
and then they get garbage
collected at a later date.
But it's usually better
in the long run
if we just create
less garbage.
If we're running in a tight--
say a tight code loop
doing some text operations,
building up a response
to send back to a server
on the other side,
a response to send
to the server...
we can actually
recycle buffers.
If we recycle objects
inside of that tight loop,
we end up creating
less garbage overall.
And there's a couple places
that this shows up
in the system.
One is XmlPullParserFactory,
and this is just an example.
It borrows from the factory
design principle,
and it also keeps
some generic state
for the entire--
for all XML pull parsers
that you might acquire.
And so using
the pull parser factory
allows you to get an instance
of a pull parser as you need it
with very low overhead.
It takes care of recycling--
recycling some of those objects.
The same with BitmapFactory
on the device
if you're acquiring bitmaps
for various things.
Using BitmapFactory
internally,
it keeps a pool
of bitmap objects
that it's prepared
to send to you,
almost pre-warmed,
ready to give to you.
Then when you're done,
you can release them back into
the pool to be recycled.
So some of these things
can really help you recycle
objects in your code.
Two other places
that this can show up--
If you do find yourselves
having to use
regular expressions,
in Java regular expression,
we compile it into a pattern,
an instance
of the pattern class.
And with that pattern class,
we can get a matcher
for a given string.
And one mistake
that I've made in my code before
is that I've acquired
a new matcher object
every single time,
for every single string
that I wanna match
that regular expression
against.
And something I need to
remind myself of
is that I can actually recycle
that matcher object.
I can call a method on it
called reset
and pass it a new string.
So this can be
a lot more efficient.
If you're writing
a tight code loop
where you're parsing
multiple strings,
you can recycle
those matcher objects.
Also in the case,
if you're building strings
for a UI,
you might end up using
something called StringBuilder.
So remember in Java
that strings are immutable,
and every time we use
the plus operator
to concatenate strings
together,
we're actually acquiring
a new string
and throwing away
the two old ones.
So something like StringBuilder
actually acquires a byte buffer
in the background,
inside of the object,
and you can append things
very cheaply to it.
And you can also recycle those
StringBuilder objects.
You call setLength,
and it actually just erases
everything that's in the string,
the StringBuilder,
allowing you to build
a brand-new string,
and you don't have to reallocate
the buffer that's underneath.
Some of these recycling issues,
you might find yourselves
working--
you can create a static object
that you might borrow
between multiple methods.
And sometimes that can introduce
synchronization issues
or correctness,
if two different threads
are borrowing
the same object in code.
And this actually is solved--
this can be solved in Android
because we're using
a single UI thread model.
If it's UI-driven,
for example,
if we're recycling
a string builder,
instead of allocating it,
let's saying you were
writing a ListView,
and there's a bindView method
where we're actually
setting the text
for the item in the ListView.
Instead of allocating
a string builder
inside of each call
of the method,
we can actually share an object,
a static object,
inside of something like
that list adaptor.
So on Android,
because it's a single
UI thread-based model,
we know that that code
is only going to ever be called,
that method is only going
to be called from the UI thread.
And we can guarantee
that the synchronization issues
are solved in those cases.
So it's something to handle
on a case-by-case basis,
but just to remember that
Android is a single UI thread.
It can help solve
some synchronization problems.
I was mentioning ListView.
ListView actually uses a lot
of recycling strategies.
If you're interesting
in digging more,
Romain Guy's talk later--
I believe it's tomorrow--
he'll be diving into ListView
a lot more
on some of the recycling
strategies
that are used in ListView.
So other ways
with foreground apps
that we can end up
saving battery.
A lot of people write
geolocation apps,
apps that need to know about
the user's location.
So something you might
want to consider
is using the coarse
network location.
So on Android we provide
two different providers
of the location of the device.
One is a network provider
and one is GPS
that the device
also happens to have.
And it ends up
that using the network provider
is a lot cheaper.
So network provider, this is
something Vic was mentioning
in his keynote earlier today
is that we might use
nearby cell towers
and WiFi access points to
triangulate where the user is.
And that can actually
be really cheap on the device.
We're just looking
at some sensors,
pulling in the cell towers
that we see,
and asking a server
to triangulate on our behalf.
And that can actually be
a lot cheaper than doing GPS.
That's because GPS fixes,
getting a fix from satellites,
the time to fix,
the time it takes us
to get a fix of our location
from the GPS satellites,
varies wildly.
It can be any length of time.
If you're out in the middle
of an open field,
the fix may only take
a few seconds.
But let's say you're in
an indoor environment like this
here in this conference
here today.
Your device may look for
GPS satellites,
and it may never find them.
We may keep the GPS radio awake
that entire time
and never actually
get a fix.
There's a risk of us
not actually getting
a latitude/longitude.
So it's something
to be aware of.
If you're interested
in just rough location,
if the accuracy
that you're interested in
is just within a couple
kilometers of where the user is,
network location
can be a lot cheaper.
So the numbers here
that we're looking at--
an average GPS fix
might take about 25 seconds.
And then we multiply that
times the actual battery
that's used during that time.
It ends up costing
about 1 milliamp hour on average
to get a GPS fix
whereas getting
a network fix
is an order
of magnitude cheaper.
We're just doing a quick,
simple network query
based on information,
the cell towers
that we already know about.
And also you notice
the Cupcake there,
something that in 1.5 we're
actually using Assisted GPS.
So when we have a GPS
and we first bring it up
on the network,
there's something known
as a cold start.
So if the user hasn't used
GPS in a while,
the device has to sit
and listen for the satellites
to send down an almanac
or a set of information
describing the movement
of the satellites.
That actually--
that can happen a lot faster
if you use something called
AGPS or Assisted GPS
where, instead of listening
for that almanac data
over a low bit rate--
the satellites are transmitting
it at all times,
but at a very low bit rate--
instead of waiting
a couple minutes
to collect that
almanac information,
AGPS goes to the network.
It assumes you have
a network connection.
It can go request
that almanac information
which allows fixes to happen
a lot faster.
So that's something
that is shipped in 1.5.
Some final things to mention
about foreground apps
is that floating point math
is expensive on the device.
The current devices
that have shipped
don't have floating point units
in their CPUs,
so doing floating point math
is expensive.
If you worked with Map Ap--
Map Activity
or Map View on the device,
you may have noticed
something called GeoPoint.
And so it's just like
a latitude/longitude,
which are decimal numbers,
except it's multiplied
by 10 to the 6.
We just shifted over
the decimal place.
So we can treat these
as integers,
which ends up being
a lot cheaper
when we're working
on the device.
And also, if you end up
writing your own views,
you may need to worry about
scaling to different densities
of devices.
A device may have
a higher density screen.
So you can actually--
and that density
is expressed in a float.
So if you're writing
your own views,
you can pre-cache that.
If you pre-multiply
that density that's coming in,
you can often cache
the value
and end up saving time
in the long run.
And one final mention.
If you're looking at using
the accelerometer
or game sensors,
there's four different rates,
four different polling rates
that you can use--
normal,
UI, game, and fastest.
They each have their own cost
associated with them.
Usually, when you're using
the accelerometer,
the user's playing a game,
so you need it anyway.
But it's just something
to be aware of,
that this is the cost
that's added on.
So we talked about network
and we talked about
foreground apps.
And finally,
I'd like to take some time
to talk about background
applications on the phone
and how they can do better
managing battery life.
So first of all,
let's back up
and talk about services
in general.
If you come from a UNIX
or a Windows background,
when we think of a service,
we think of something
we start in the background
and it continues to run,
almost like a daemon.
So it's waiting for
a request to come in.
It's running at all times.
And that works really well
in the desktop world.
but in the mobile world,
each of those processes running,
each of those services
has an overhead
associated with it.
So say, for example,
some of the devices
that first came out,
say the HTC Dream device
that came out--
when the system
finally boots...
so we think we have
an amount of RAM on the system,
and the system boots.
We have an amount of RAM
that's reserved for the kernel
and then we have some RAM
that's reserved for
the Android framework.
And when the device
finally finishes booting,
we have roughly about
30 to 40 megabytes of actual RAM
that applications--
that foreground applications
and background apps
on the device can make use of.
And something to be aware of--
that each process on the device,
even if you're running
a lightweight service,
takes somewhere around
2 megabytes of overhead
just to start that
application,
and that's just the foundation
of starting your app.
If you're doing other things
on top of that,
that's even more RAM
that you end up using.
And then finally,
if you have a service
that's running
in the background constantly,
the system
will actually kill you.
If the user is doing
some foreground task
say like using the browser
and the browser needs
more memory,
it will go through
and kill off
some of these background
services.
And it will try restarting you
at a later time
so you can continue
whatever work you were doing
in the background.
But again, that overhead
having to kill you
and then come back
and restart you
can really add up over time.
Okay, so we asked the question,
if we can't have
the service running
at all times in the background,
if we can't use a daemon model
that works really well
on the desktop,
how should we write services?
There's two primary methods
that we can use.
One is if you have a point
in the future,
have a time in the future
that you know you need
to wake up--
say you're performing
an RSS feed update
every 15 minutes
or half an hour--
you can set an alarm
for the system to wake you up
at that point in the future.
And another method
is using a broadcast receiver,
so it allows you
to be event-driven.
So if the user moves between
network connections--
for example,
if they're on an EDGE network
and they transfer to a 3G,
if they all of the sudden
get a 3G connection,
on broadcast intents--
the system sends out
broadcast intents
that anyone interested
can pick up on and handle.
So those are just two--
I'll jump into those more
in detail--
but those are
two of the methods
that you should use
as writing services.
And a final note is,
once you handle--
if your service is woken up
and you handle
one of these events,
make sure to call stopSelf
if you're writing the service
which tells the system
that you're finished
with whatever work
you were doing,
and the system
can kill your process.
It's free to kill your process.
So remember to stopSelf whenever
you're done processing data.
So first, let's jump into
those two types,
using AlarmManager,
and then later we'll talk about
the broadcast intents.
So first AlarmManager.
If you have a point in time
in the future
that you know you'd like
to wake up,
you can have the system wake
you up to perform that action.
So this--it allows you
to set a time, a specific time
using the notion of an RTC
or a real-time clock.
So if you're familiar with
the concept of UNIX time
on Android,
the RTC is the number
of seconds--
the number of milliseconds
since the epoch, back in 1970.
So you can specify
an exact time
that you'd like the system
to wake you up
to perform some action
in the future.
You can also specify--
you can add in a flag.
So here at the bottom,
we're using
the AlarmManager.RTC flag.
There's other flags
that we can use.
We can use RTC_WAKEUP,
and what that does,
that forces the device awake.
So if we get to that point
in time
and we absolutely need
the device to wake up--
Let's say, for example,
we're writing an alarm clock.
We need to wake up and tell
the user to get out of bed.
We want to wake the device up
if it's sleeping,
so we should use
a wake-up flag.
Otherwise,
if we don't use that,
the service will only start
at that point in the future
if the system is already awake,
if it's awake
handling other things
on behalf of the user.
So another thing
we introduced in Cupcake--
we have the notion
of repeating alarms.
We can set an alarm.
Say you wanted
to update your RSS feed
or you have a Twitter feed
that you want to update
every 15 minutes or so.
Currently, right now, the old
approach in the 1.1 SDK,
you set a repeating alarm
and you set an interval.
You set 15 minutes,
and the system would actually
set those alarms.
So here on the left-hand side,
this is an example
of what it used to look like.
Let's say you had a Twitter
and a news app
and a mail application
that all wanted to wake up,
say every half hour,
in this case.
So we would run into
the worst-case circumstance
where the Twitter application
would wake up,
and then the system would
fall back asleep,
go into an idle state
for about ten minutes.
And then the news application
would wake the device up
and do an update
and then fall back asleep
for another ten minutes.
And then the mail application--
you can see how
that's the worst case,
all of these being spread out
across time.
And the overhead associated
with waking up the system
each time to go do
network activity
and falling back asleep,
there's all that extra overhead.
So something we introduced
in 1.5 is the notion--
AlarmManager has a new method
called setinexactRepeating
which allows you
as a developer,
if you're willing
to be flexible
with the time interval
that you're woken up with,
if you say, I'm okay with being
woken up every 30 minutes-ish,
if you're okay
being adjusted around,
the system will offer
to bin you together.
It will bin you together
with anyone else
that's interested in updating
at the same interval.
So in this case,
those three applications
that they use
setinexactRepeating,
the system would group them
all together.
It would look and compare
and group everyone together
to do one single update.
It would wake up the device,
perform all three updates,
and then fall asleep
for an entire half hour
until the next set
of updates happened.
So that's something to be
aware of in the 1.5 SDK
if you're looking to do
some things in the background.
[coughs]
Okay, so that covers
AlarmManager.
One of the other methods that
you can wake up from a service
or wake your service up
is using the notion
of broadcast intents.
so the system--
here's just a couple examples
that can be really useful
for developers.
For example,
if the times aren't changed,
if you're writing an application
that wakes the person up,
maybe you're interested
in that
or if you have
a calendar application.
The second one is probably
one of the most important--
ConnectivityManager.
Something happened
with the network connection.
We changed.
We were on EDGE before.
Now we're connected to WiFi,
or maybe we lost network
connection all together.
Or maybe we didn't have
network connection,
and now we're connected
to WiFi.
That broadcast intent,
that ConnectivityManager.
Connectivity_Action
is sent out by the system
every time
the network state changes.
So that's something
you can listen for.
The same if you--
Let's say you're holding
a cache on the device,
and you're interested when
the device storage is low.
Maybe you have a cache
that you can clean out
to help make room
for the user.
You can listen
for that broadcast.
Or if you're doing
some background tasks,
you can listen for
the battery low broadcast.
So the system
will send this out
at the same time that it shows
the notification to the user
that they have 15%
of their battery left.
If you're doing
some background tasks,
you might fall asleep
during this period
and wake yourself up
maybe a day later
when you might have
more battery.
So you could use that
to cancel some background tasks.
So this is
one quick code snippet
about how you'd register
for these.
So just like we have
an activity
or in our service definition
in our Android manifest,
we define a receiver
and then an intent filter
that matches
any of those intents
that we're interested in.
So part of the issue
is that ConnectivityManager
actually happens a lot
on the device.
As I was mentioning,
if these were moving between
EDGE and WiFi,
every single one
of those actions
will wake up your service
because you've told the system
that you're interested
in that update.
It will wake you up every time.
And the risk is that--
let's say you're writing
an application
that uploads video,
say to YouTube,
on behalf of the user.
If you register
for this broadcast,
the risk
is that most of the time,
the user isn't going to have
a video waiting in the queue
to upload.
They might not have
anything to do.
So your process, your server,
your service that you're writing
will be woken up
for every one of these
connectivity change events,
even when you don't have
anything to do.
And that can cause
a lot of overhead.
So one way to solve that
is actually
enabling and disabling
those manifest elements.
So we define
the manifest element
using that receiver tag.
We can programmatically,
at run-time,
enable and disable it,
so we can get those broadcast
intents when we need them,
when we need to know
about them,
and we can turn them off
when we know we wouldn't
be doing anything.
So something like this--
this is a code example
at the top here.
We're starting with
enabled="false."
We're not gonna receive
any of those broadcast actions.
Then in the code later on,
let's say the user has a video
that they're ready to upload.
In that code,
we can actually grab a copy
of the package manager
and find the component name
for our broadcast receiver.
And we can dynamically
enable it
so that we start receiving
those broadcast intents
so that as we're uploading
the video,
we watch to see as the user
changes between WiFi
to EDGE to 3G so that
we can handle it correctly.
And then, the same code
works in the inverse case.
Once we've finished uploading
everything
on behalf of the user,
we can go and disable
this manifest element again
because we don't have anything
left in our upload queue,
and we would just be
using system resources
when we don't have anything
to upload.
So this can really help us
be more efficient.
Another thing that we can do
is, actually,
we can check
the battery state.
And this is a little bit
of a tricky code example.
You can check to see the battery
percentage that's left.
The system sends out
a broadcast intent,
a sticky broadcast
that sticks around
that you can catch that has
the current battery level,
say it'd be like 40% or 45%.
And so you might be interested
in getting that exact number
so that you could do
some calculations.
So if the user's on EDGE
and they have more than
60% battery,
maybe it's okay, and you wanna
go ahead with that.
So this is a quick code snippet
that would explain
how to go grab that broadcast.
It's a little bit hard
to explain,
and we're running
a little short on time,
so we'll skip it for now.
Okay, so we talked about
how we as developers
can save battery,
both in terms of network,
foreground apps,
and background apps.
So now let's talk about
what's beyond 1.5,
beyond Cupcake.
What's coming next?
So here I'd like to show
an example.
This is actually in SpareParts
on Cupcake.
It's not on your phones
that you got today,
because those are
user builds.
If you go home, you should
be able t flash your phones,
re-flash your phones
with an engineering build
which will give you root,
and it will start collecting
battery statistics.
So this is an example
of what that screen looks like.
The system is actually
keeping track in 1.5 now
of each of the applications
and how much they're doing
with respect to various
pieces on the system.
In this case, we're looking
at how much network activity
each of the apps,
and we're tabulating,
we're keeping these statistics.
So it's something
that's not exposed just yet,
but in future versions
down the road,
this is something we'd like
to expose to end users.
So they know, for instance,
that "My device's battery
doesn't last very long.
What can I do about it?"
So this will be an answer.
This will be a place
that they can go
and actually check to see
who on their phone--
which applications
are using battery.
So this is something
that you guys can use
as you're working and
debugging your applications,
but it's also motivation.
It's also motivation
to be aware
that users will be watching
in the future,
and they'll be able to see
which apps are using battery.
And they'll actually
uninstall you,
and then you won't be around.
So one thing to keep in mind,
if you're writing apps,
give your users flexibility.
Say, for example, you're writing
a stock ticker application.
Some of your users
may only be interested
in getting updates
once or twice a day.
But other users
may be really interested
and want updates
every five minutes.
So giving your users flexibility
on how much they want to update
will make them less likely
to uninstall you.
Because they have a choice.
They have some control
over the amount of battery
that your application is using
if they can change preferences
inside of your app.
So some overall takeaways
about everything
we talked about today.
First of all,
use an efficient data parser.
Use one of those event
or pull-base parsers
instead of a tree parser.
Also use GZIP
to compress text data
if you're sending a lot of
textual data to the phone
so that you can save
network and CPU resources.
Services that sleep or poll
are bad.
So don't use the daemon
approach from the desktop.
Instead, be event-driven.
Set alarms for yourself
to wake up in the future
and respond
to broadcast intents.
Also disable
those manifest elements.
If you're interested
in those broadcasts,
disable them
when you wouldn't do anything.
If the system
is just going to wake you up
to look and decide
that you're going to fall
back asleep again, disable it.
Disable those manifest elements
in those cases.
Also, wake up along
with everyone else.
That's the set inexact alarms
repeating alarms.
Also wait for a better network
or battery
before you do bulk transfers,
and possibly involve
the user in that process
so that they know they can
go find WiFi somewhere to--
if it's going to affect
their battery life.
And finally,
give choices to the user
about the background behavior
of your apps.
It'll allow them to--
you'll be much more friendly
towards users,
because they have choices,
they have a choice now
between how much battery
you're using in the background.
So with that, that's about
all I had to talk about
about battery life.
It looks like we have just over
five, six minutes left
for questions.
So I'm gonna switch over
to Google Moderator,
and then also feel free
to come up to the microphones
to ask any of your questions.
Then we'll alternate
back and forth
between everything.
Okay, so first question
on Moderator.
Someone asked, "What happened
to the GoogleIO apps?
I can't find it on market!"
So over the weekend,
a couple friends and I
wrote an application for
the schedule for the conference,
and you can find it on market.
You can only get it
on Cupcake devices.
If you go to market and just
search for IO as a single word,
you should be able
to find it.
Let's take a live question
over here on the left.
man: Yeah, real quick.
You didn't mention
the overhead involved
with UDP transmissions.
How does that compare?
Sharkey: Okay.
That's a good question.
So, right, there's a little
more overhead TCP connections
'cause we need to build up
the entire transaction.
There's a syn-ack process
that happens between both ends.
So there's more latency
involved.
So there's a little more
setup time there.
I would expect the UDP...
UDP is cheaper,
but when you think about it,
the devices are running
on mobile networks
that are definitely
not as reliable,
so UDP doesn't give you
any guarantees
that your message actually got
to the other end.
So most cases,
you do wanna use TCP
just because you'll have
that guarantee
that it made it across
the mobile network,
which might be flaky.
So UDP might offer you
some savings,
but I'd say in the long run,
you're probably gonna want
to go with TCP.
Let's take a question
over on the right.
man: Me?
Sharkey: Yeah, yeah.
man: What about screen
brightness?
How does that affect
the battery?
Sharkey: So I took a peek
at that,
so there's the 0% brightness
on the screen.
You can turn it all the way
down so it's very, very dim.
It ended up still taking
quite a bit of battery.
I think it was about
70 milliamps
at the lowest brightness.
And part of that was because
we're actually driving
the entire LCD.
We have that refresh rate
of up to 60 hertz
that we're pushing pixels,
so there was a lot of cost
with that.
And it was a little higher.
I think it was about 100, 110
if we had it at 100% brightness.
So roughly in that ballpark.
So the sweet spot
that the device--
someone asked the question
in the crowd,
what is the sweet spot
for the display brightness?
And the default one
that ships with the device
that most users
don't change it from,
that's the number
that I mentioned there,
which is about 90 milliamps
that it ends up costing.
That's right in the middle
of the road.
Let's take a couple questions
from the Moderator,
Someone asked, "Are there any
battery profiling tools
out there?"
And the short answer is,
sadly, no, there isn't.
However, there's
a direct correlation
between how much processing,
how much CPU you're using
and the impact
on battery life.
So if you're using tools--
so if you're using TraceView,
which is one of the tools
that's distributed with the SDK
to look at the amount of time
that your code is running,
it allows you to do
method level tracing
to see how many times
methods are called
and how much time overall
your app is taking
for certain operations.
If you're using TraceView,
that's a good indicator
of how much battery you're using
on the other side.
So, sad to say, there aren't
any direct profiling tools
kind of because
measuring milliamps
is somewhat
of an electronic black art.
You can't do it in software.
You actually need specific
hardware to directly measure it.
Take one more question
from Moderator.
"How can you customize the power
management features of Android
to enable more power modes?"
So this is actually--
the base Android system
doesn't come with very much
profile management,
but this is a place we've
actually seen in the Market.
Several apps have stepped up
to the challenge
and written apps
that help the user
manage their battery life.
So, for example,
Locale was one of the winners
of the first ADC
which allows you to change
your network preferences
to turn on WiFi when it sees
that you're getting near home
and to turn Bluetooth off
when you start getting
on the train,
'cause you wanna listen to music
on your Bluetooth headset.
So there's apps out there--
as of right now,
I don't think
there's any plans
of including that
in the platform.
I think it's a niche
that third-party apps
have filled very well.
Let's take a question
from the right.
man: I actually have
a question that's quite long.
So one is--can you go back
to the slides of the sensor,
the gaming side?
So, uh...and how you
calculate--yes.
How you calculated 10 milliamps.
Actually, accelerometer itself
only consume less than
half milliamps.
And what is like a--
Sharkey: Right, right.
Okay, so that's a good question.
He's asking, the actual
sensor in the device uses--
is very little power,
the accelerometer in the device,
the hardware,
the piece of hardware
that measures the accelerometer.
That device
uses very little power,
only a couple milliamps.
The overhead
that we're seeing here,
the cost between
these polling rates,
is because the device
is shipping that information,
those details,
the accelerometer,
the actual measurements,
up into Java code.
And that's where we start
to see the overhead.
We have to marshal that
into the Java environment.
And that's where we see
the overhead.
That's where we start seeing
this battery life.
So these battery measurements
aren't strictly the cost
of running the accelerometer.
They're the overhead of actually
having to pass that information
back up into the Java world.
man: Along that, so how you
think we can reduce that
by like interrupt driven by--
interrupt
for orientation detection
and you can reduce
the traffic?
Sharkey: Okay, so this--
man: So because...
I think the sensor manager
in the Android
do not take interrupt.
Sharkey: Okay, right now
the sensor manager's
just available from Java code,
so we're stuck with
this overhead right now.
With some of the other stuff
that Dan Morrill was covering
this morning,
talking about writing
native code,
I don't know if there's efforts
to have sensor manager available
in native code,
but that would actually help
save some of this overhead.
If you're writing C++ code
that can look directly
at the sensor values,
you can really help
save some battery.
You don't have the overhead
of going all the way up to Java.
Again, it's something
I'm not aware of
that people are working on
right now,
but it definitely would help
in the long run
for game developers.
Let's take a couple more
questions from Moderator,
'cause these are the ones
that you guys have voted up
over the course of the talk.
Okay, someone asked
the question,
"What is the rule of thumb
for employing caching of data
"to avoid repeated data
transmissions
and, consequently,
draining the battery?"
I have about ten seconds left,
so I'll quickly try to answer
this question.
So on the device,
probably the best place
to store a data cache
is on the SD card.
When you store it
in the internal directory,
internal structure for your app,
you're actually counting
against the space
that the user could be
installing other apps into.
So it's probably best
to use the SD card.
You can also check
the SD card state
using the environment object
in Java.
With that, I think we're
about half a minute past time.
I'd be happy to talk
with any of you guys.
If you have questions
afterwards, come up and talk.
Thanks for your time.
[applause]